the voicemail number that you can call
24 hours a day is two one nine to david
p here is a protoss re here's a caller
who doesn't care if the protesters died
of coronavirus but unfortunately it's
more complicated than that take a listen
hey David I know this is sort of
unpopular say especially with like
knowing your views but honestly dude I
don't care if some of these protesters
died as a result of their irresponsible
actions I get it
the problem is other people will also
die I'm mostly on board with if this is
truly a sort of natural selection type
thing where if the protesters want to
protest and they are the only ones that
sick of at risk of getting sick and
dying at a certain point it's like okay
let them do it now the problem is some
of them are bringing their kids are
their kids really able to consent to
that
do the kids really understand the risks
I don't think so but if you imagine only
the protesters are the ones that risk
dying by protesting at certain point I
would say fine just let him do it the
problem is they become spreaders of the
disease and so while you are right you
were also missing that it's a fantasy to
imagine that the protesters are only
putting themselves at risk that's the
problem on today's bonus show we will
talk about news that North Korean leader
Kim jong-un is very ill after surgery
yet another 20/20 thing that uh is is
stacking up for a very crazy situation
we will also talk about what's going on
amidst the pandemic in Italy with the
Mafia and we will talk about the Supreme
Court guaranteeing the right to a
unanimous verdict in serious criminal
trials very interesting and important
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show don't miss it get instant
access by signing up at join pakman.com